mercedes-amg driver's seat brought to
you by a Mercedes AMG be prepared for
whatever comes your way the all-new GT
4-door coupe because life's a race visit
your local dealership for a test drive
today we had the opportunity earlier
this year earlier this season to connect
with Melissa Etheridge over the phone
and then in person in Los Angeles she
did a song for us with a stat of the day
so very sweet and she was going to be
doing the anthem yesterday in Kansas
City grew up a Chiefs fan and we thought
you know what Chiefs at home and their
number one seed chance to go to the
Super Bowl
let's book her for Monday it'll be a
great moment she sings the anthem and
the Chiefs are going to the Super Bowl
what a half was right
she's sang the anthem and did a great
job as always but the Chiefs are not
going to the Super Bowl in the
singer-songwriter Melissa Etheridge
joining us on the program how's morale
today Melissa you know it's that morning
after and I got say even though even
though I'm waking up here in Kansas City
it's freezing cold it was quite a night
we haven't had a night like that it was
such a game and I feel like there's so
much talent in that locker room and I
don't feel like it's a fluke I feel like
you know here we go I'm I'm that morning
after football fan that's like we got it
next year yeah we're undefeated already
are you in denial yeah you're just like
any any other fan but but this was this
one where you know you got a chance to
go to the Super Bowl yeah see that's a
great when we beat the Colts we went
further than you know we have in a
generation we went further and so this
was this was amazing but you know yeah
it was hard to see that it's hard to
just sit there and watch Tom Brady just
throw to Edelman you know it's just hard
it's hard to go God you know and of
course we'll talk about our defense but
it was just it was a great game you know
do you hate Tom Brady do I know I don't
hate anybody I I appreciate you
is greatness I appreciate his ability
you know double check the other hand I
don't know well take me through your day
when you're preparing for the anthem how
do you how do you prepare oh well you
did that's a mental thing because the
national anthem is one of the hardest
songs to sing on earth it is there's
nothing really melodic or nice about it
you can't you know you just got to jump
right into it and you also know that if
you mess it up that's that possibly
could be your career that's gonna stay
with you forever and ever and ever and
so there's no just a little bit of
nervousness but yeah I just yeah I get
there and I get the thing for a first
soundcheck so I went out and realized
just how cold it was going to be in how
the it was cold but is it also that
first when you that first note or the
first like when you first sing because
you got to be on the right pitch when
you sing the anthem it feels like it can
get out of hand sometimes and I don't
know pregame to real game and noise and
all of that and it's cold and the
cameras are on you and all of a sudden
you got to make sure you start out on
the right pitch or it's gonna go
sideways oh you got to start low you got
such a silly girl I don't ever use like
a pitchfork or you know a tuning you
know pitch pitch pipe whatever those are
this is you know you may have used its
fork yesterday on Bella Jackman you know
you know you just I just in my head it's
like oh hey I know I know I gotta hit
that that first notes gotta be low so I
sort of sing that those first three
notes over and over and over in my head
so that you know when they're announcing
they mo say oh say so I don't know say
you know I can't I find this interesting
with fans that I always feel like when
you over achieve you do a little more
than people thought if I would have said
at the beginning of the year to you
Melissa the Chiefs are gonna go to the
AFC title game but you're gonna lose in
overtime to Tom Brady and dramatic
would you sign up for that or would you
rather take you know a season where you
don't make the playoffs or you have a
first round exit no no I give me this
AFC championship game this was huge it
really was and losing to the goats okay
you know we lost to the greatest so it's
okay alright that's okay
do we do that on music do we designate
goat like no we don't I know well I
think you know we went like Elvis
Presley and maybe you know Aretha
Franklin maybe but uh but it's so you
know it's subjective it's so they're
subject I forget which one that is but
it's so if someone's tastes and someone
who likes me somebody else certainly
might not like my music and you know
that's I don't think you can say the
greatest really in music at all hmm
howling competition like you know how
many passes you can throw and stuff that
sort of thing well unless it's like
number one or hits or album sales or
Grammys or thing I don't know if we keep
track of that and say you know that's a
way to tell who is one of the greatest
or the greatest of all time yeah because
then it becomes you know I'm Taylor
Swift and that kind of thing so you know
cuz sales are are funny too who knows
did you meet Patrick mahomes I did not I
didn't know you know what my favorite
part of singing the anthems every time I
step down Andy Reed hugs me so I hugged
Andy Reed twice he's just he stands
right in front of me when I say man it's
really something that's by design I
think are you gonna watch the Super Bowl
Melissa oh I'll say no until sometime
and then I will you know because I'm
that fan it was like I know I see Brady
dude whatever you know whatever but um
yeah I'll watch it because I'm a huge
football fan and I love it and that's
just it's the it's the end game and then
we start all over again and you you said
you you talked about maybe coming up
with a song and we thought
a song called the gunslinger for Patrick
mahomes a little rockabilly song about
the gunslinger are you working on that
well you know it's funny I kept thinking
no I'm not gonna do it this year you
really want to see what's gonna happen
here yeah I put you next year I bet you
next year when we start rolling into the
season and I'm all excited again you
know I'll have a little more backstory
to write on a on a song you know I can
talk about the last show down in
Arrowhead or something you know maybe
next year but you know sometimes pain
brings about the best kind of music
first 20 years of my career it's going
too well for you Melissa that's the
problem now you got a little pain now
you tap into that it'll be a hit yes it
will yes you've been a great sport with
your time sorry didn't end the way you
thought or hoped but we appreciate you
joining the program and thanks again
thank you I again think the Chiefs
they've just they allowed me the
opportunity to sing the anthem and it
just meant a lot to me and they just did
a great job and then they can hold their
heads up they just really really did
well and see you next year
Thank You Melissa thank you Dan that's
Melissa Etheridge you know what how this
happened is I asked Melissa being a
Chiefs fan I have you ever sang the
anthem and she said I have but not with
the Chiefs and then the Chiefs were
listening somebody in their front office
and then they reached out to Melissa and
then brought her in to sing the anthem
so that's pretty cool if you missed any
of our interviews this week from the
mercedes-amg man cave go to the Dan
Patrick show app you can watch and
listen from inside the mercedes-amg man
cave mercedes-amg driving performance
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]